SPEAKER 1: We continue our
Education in America series
this morning with one man
who is turning the learning
process upside down.
SPEAKER 2: His series
of really simple videos
is being called revolutionary,
as CBS News correspondent John
Blackstone reports.
JOHN BLACKSTONE:
It would be music
to the ears of any educator,
what 10-year-old Megan
Tsern has to say about
her favorite teacher.
MEGAN TSERN: He makes
math really easy
in a really kind of
conversational way.
SALMAN KHAN: It would
be on the number line.
JOHN BLACKSTONE:
He is Salman Khan.
SALMAN KHAN: It's negative $7.
It's like saying that I owe $7.
JOHN BLACKSTONE:
Khan is the voice
and the brains behind
the Khan Academy,
the free educational
website that some believe
is leading a
revolution in teaching.
SALMAN KHAN:
There's no nonsense.
There's no defocusing
on the material.
It really is what it is.
JOHN BLACKSTONE: Khan's lessons
are unscripted and unadorned.
SALMAN KHAN: Let's divide both
sides of this equation by--
JOHN BLACKSTONE: His
voice over a black screen
as he writes or doodles.
His style has changed little
since this all began back
in 2004 as YouTube videos
to help his young cousins.
SALMAN KHAN: 9 times the 6.
JOHN BLACKSTONE:
He's now recorded
more than 2,400
lessons on everything
from simple arithmetic
to college-level biology.
Anyone can watch for free.
SALMAN KHAN: People are
more likely to say thank you
when it's free.
And you know, thank
you is worth a lot.
JOHN BLACKSTONE: But what
are Khan's lessons worth?
The Los Altos School District
is trying to figure that out.
Last year, the district used
Khan's lessons in five classes.
The students did well enough
that this year the Khan method
is in 40 classes, to be used
by every fifth and sixth grader
in the district.
ALYSSA GALLAGHER: We found
that our students are really
engaged in this
type of learning,
that it was a great addition
to what we were already doing.
JOHN BLACKSTONE: You
might say this California
School has flipped.
Students get their
lectures at home
and come to school
to do their homework,
fundamentally changing
the role of the teacher.
COURTNEY CADWELL: The kids
can really move through
at their own pace, and then
I can see who's struggling.
JOHN BLACKSTONE:
At home, students
listen to Khan's online lessons.
In the classroom,
they practice what
they learned while teacher
Courtney Cadwell works
with those who need help.
COURTNEY CADWELL: When
they're having fun
and they're wanting
to do math, that
tells me that this
is a good thing.
JOHN BLACKSTONE: This
educational overhaul
comes from a man who was
working as a hedge fund analyst
until 2009.
Khan has a Harvard MBA and
three degrees from MIT.
You're kind of a math
geek, I guess, are you?
SALMAN KHAN: Yes, in the
best form of the word.
JOHN BLACKSTONE:
In the beginning,
he financed the Khan Academy
from his own savings,
until he was discovered
by some people with money.
BILL GATES: Well, it's amazing.
I think you've
just got a glimpse
of the future of education.
Thank you.
JOHN BLACKSTONE: The Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation
and Google are among
the big donors that
have allowed the Khan Academy
to add nearly a dozen software
engineers.
MEGAN TSERN: It's really
smartly done on the computer,
and I love being
on the computer.
JOHN BLACKSTONE: With more
than two million users a month,
many others seem to love
Khan's lessons, too.
SALMAN KHAN: I've already
taught 70 million lessons.
JOHN BLACKSTONE: And he will be
happy to teach millions more.
SALMAN KHAN: Smallest
to the largest.
JOHN BLACKSTONE: John
Blackstone, CBS News.
Mountain View, California.